but now you're one of those rare actors
who you quite like the green screen and
not knowing what's there yeah yeah I
prefer that over the actual animals he
hates animals yeah he has a real fear I
don't know yes yeah I'm sorry I respect
don't stop saying fear but you're saying
it in a way and they're gonna take it
and run it's not a fear it's a I don't
understand what you're thinking about so
I don't like to be around you because I
can't I can't get it's just a poodle
listen too much to get into cuz you're
gonna judge me and I don't but did you
get to meet cuz obviously don't you
didn't get to meet a herd of ostriches
yeah but but did you meet like who's
your on location for some of it well you
know I mean for a lot of it we wanted to
expand the Jumanji universe so we went
from the jungle then we went to the
dunes and we went to the desert that we
went to the snow-capped mountains in
Calgary Alberta Canada and we were
there's a massive scene we're on camels
Kevin got to know his camel very very
well terrified of character very racist
camel let's get it out animals are races
the only black guy that was there cam
will definitely had it out for me did he
not does any other camel making noise
except mine any other camel making
noises Kevin well here's the thing as
you guys know like animals they feed off
the energy of the king and he had a very
fearful energy I'm racist against myself
it was that the camel was not it was not
a nice camel grandma the camel life
Azhar is like the camel that you climbed
aboard come on was making happy noises
how do you have three hops because you
swelled the middle section out because
you're so big
[Music]
you